what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today these
jackets make noise listen noise to tva
jackets we're gonna watch the second
episode of loki today
very excited to check this out of course
the first episode was
awesome guys if you haven't done so
already be sure to hit that like button
if you end up enjoying our video
also subscribe and click that
notification bell and as always full
length watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code or over at our
patreon page cover a whole bunch of
shows over there we're at the same tier
you get the option for both the reaction
highlights and watch along
included last but certainly not least
pratham jindal
thank you so much for all the hard work
you've been doing buddy i think you've
been killing it so far
so thanks for uh editing down the
highlights for us
i'm sorry for yelling at you he's never
apologized to me about that
you deserved it i do pray
you kind of deserve it too but
that's just me being a good boss please
don't leave
yeah no this is the real wisconsin
[Music]
mind control
come a long way from working with
hellboy
time door
[Music]
what if that variant's really the hero
and
the tva or the baddies are you recording
or are you alive
uh sort of bows
watch it where's your manners yeah my
jet ski magazine put it down come on
gear up there's been an attack let's go
it's so fuzzy to be just like an office
worker i know
office location tva
c20 and her team went dark shortly after
they jumped into the 1985 branch
but which kind of loki remains unknown
they're the lesser kind
to be clear type we should all be very
familiar with
because the tva has pruned a lot of
these guys almost more than any other
bear
differences in appearances or nuts oh
cool
yo i had my magic back is no one
concerned about that
what me betraying you no you already
know that we can catch you in house
betraying us going to get you any closer
to the timekeepers
keep that focus
let's go
so he's taking hostages now the
variant's never taken a hostage before
hurry up because we're at three units
until red line oh
wait i see a scheme and in that scheme i
see myself
two units he is wasting our time need to
look for c-20
that's exactly what the variant wants
you to do it's waiting for you outside
this tent should i ask you the research
artist no he wants me i'm the key to his
plan
he knows that i'm stronger than him a
new
purpose i'm a servant of the sacred
timeline
sure i need assurances that i won't be
completely disintegrated the moment the
job has been done
i will need to speak to the timekeepers
at once they're in greater danger than
we realized
flying just playing games there's no one
out there
you set the timeline
dang my ears are sharp dude
man owen wilson i love him
he's so good i love him so much that was
a magnificent pause
and how are the old time keepers how do
you think
i don't know because i've never met him
really they want that variant caught
so do i and this is the last chance
you're gonna get with this loki
great that's all i'm gonna need
thank you for slayer
lefty there's what does it say you don't
remember this this must be from that
franklin roosevelt and hey if it doesn't
work i'll delete him myself
he's really arrogant
you're probably wondering what happened
out on the mission
i'm so worried about being deleted in
catching a loki
expect the expected huh
i believe stupidly that insecure need
for validation
would motivate you to find the killer
this variant is better than you
you can't take it oh dude
why are you in there sticking on that
couch for me i'll give you two
options and you can believe whichever
one you want a because i see a scared
little boy
for b i just want to catch this guy and
i'll tell you whatever i need to tell
you
oh i love this
wow we're taking you to the men in black
i wonder if we will see the timekeepers
in this epi in the show
let me park you at this desk and don't
be afraid to really lean into this world
pretend your life depends on it
[Laughter]
he's so good at just being nonchalant um
i like
all files pertaining to the creation of
the tva
those are classified okay i like all
files pertaining to the beginning of
time then
those are classified at the end of time
there's a class okay what files can i
have
what files can i have
destruction of asgard that's right we
didn't see that in
[Music]
oh he's hiding in apocalypses
ragnarok are you familiar yes the
destruction of asgard and most of its
people
i'm sorry yes very sad anyway it got me
thinking
whoa
[Applause]
be any apocalypse it could pompey
everything and
everyone around you is destined for
imminent destruction
then nothing that i say or do
will matter because the timeline's not
going to branch
variant be hiding in the apocalypse and
do whatever he wants and we
wouldn't no
i feel like he's exploited like three
times
you gotta properly test this theory
trust me
i love to be right
perfect yeah the pompe there it is
bhutan
eagerness
this is the most gleefully bleak scene
believe it zero variance energy no
branching in the timeline damn
if it were me this is where i would hide
get out doing this been ambushing our
soldiers and hiding out in doomsday oh
this show's so cool
love this no warning no survivors how
many of those disasters could they
possibly be i don't know we're gonna
find out
there is like that tom hanks dicaprio
five from casualty yeah
yeah absolutely lizards time keepers
created the tva
and everyone in it right including you
including me
you see every time i start to admire
intelligence you say something like that
existence is chaos
nothing makes any sense so we try to
make some sense of it
and i'm just lucky that the chaos i
emerged into
gave me all this it's real
great it's real because i believe it's
real
so everything is written there's no such
thing as free will
you and i here at the tva we're the only
ones who are actually free
you know you called me a scared little
boy i called you a lot of things
you see i know something children don't
but no one bad is ever truly bad
and no one good is ever truly good
it's a big grey world you're very clever
i know marion left something behind in
an old crime
scene now we have two variables
apocalyptic natural disasters
and blue louie was only sold regionally
on earth from 2047 to 2051. all you got
to do is cross
reference that with every apocalyptic
event i'm going to give you half and
let's make it a competition see who
finds it
okay what do you want to bet something
yeah yeah let's play for a bride okay
best man go let's play for pride it's
free for friday
it's not the climate disaster of 2048 oh
god
extinction of the swallow another thing
completely screwed up the ecosystem
cramming volcanoes
that's where he is alabama 2050 haven
hills
the future take my job if i'm not
careful
that's his true goal this is all based
on a theory from the variant who just
blew your previous mission
yeah he's doing great
oh god you can handle him
so it's so good it's like when you hire
a hacker to work for you
every instinct is telling me this is
where we nail the variant
oh boy okay yes
why isn't this show 24 episodes
[Music]
[Laughter]
just in case
damn it oh
wow
wow goodbye alabama
so awesome i'm so in love with this i
could cry just never
ever want to stop watching hey loki and
i are going to check out the greenhouse
we'll meet back at the showroom
you go with d90 he stays with me he's
under my supervision this is my field of
mobius
you can trust me i understand i have to
earn that
so i will
why is it the people you can't trust are
always saying
trust me
[Music]
oh yeah yeah yeah
i for one i'm glad we're getting to
spend this time
what are you doing shopping for plants
could that be you yes maybe
he knows it's not him
oh oh no no oh no
you're the fool the tva brought in to
hunt me down
me i presume
[Music]
hi are you guys looking for the disaster
shelter no
[Music]
oh bless you're going to call your
little friends for help
god it's music
were you too scared to meet me face to
face you know gaining their confidence
was no mean feat
i'm going to overthrow the timekeepers i
could use a qualified lieutenant
i'm not interested in ruling the time
variants authority
i gave it away the time keepers where
they are i gave it away how to find them
that's your plan lure us all here so you
could blow the place up
[Music]
oh
what happened looks like your favorite
loki betrayed you
just move shut up man you don't know him
he's trying to betray you or maybe he's
not
brace yourself loki
[Music]
this isn't about you
[Music]
oh damn
[Music]
oh wow oh wow
where are they going
oh no somebody just bought the sacred
timeline
oh god
[Music]
oh
oh
no don't go loki don't go
[Music]
oh
what mad i am in love with this so
so much this is great television this is
this is great it's freaking everything i
wanted
so worried for him i know like no you're
like they're really good at inflicted
and riding that razor's head
or someone you should feel that's the
only way he can find the answers by
following her too
man wow let's chit chat about that
amazing ass
television episode i'm gonna wait till
this show is done
to tell you if it's my favorite of the
three
that have come out this year because
it's so early on
until already me declared that but i'm
like
we should wait yeah we should wait the
smart thing to do would be
to wait don't jump the gun but right now
um i am just so like they they just
can't
they did everything they did from the
first episode but even more so
and adding in the additional uh
intensity of like it there's almost that
traditional plot
you know like the writer michael waldron
or creator he said
how when he was writing for owen wilson
he was looking for like
he was the mobius character he was
imagining like a tom hanks
and then it really clicked with me in
this episode of kind of like a catch if
you can dynamic the last
act of that movie where you guys haven't
seen it i'm sorry
but it's based on your old spoilers it's
based on a true story
about uh a thief who eventually started
working with the fbi and it's following
tom hanks and
dicaprio as a young guy and then
eventually they start working together
and it's kind of like that dynamic
working with the criminal
but then there's also this uh great like
you know how they talked about like a
buddy cop thing for falcon and winter
soldier
yeah that seems like even a million
times more prevalent here between the
two of them
uh them working together solving this
mystery together but then
learning to be friends and it's so cool
how this show
thrusts you into the perspective of
do i i don't even know i don't even know
if i should trust loki you know
no that's magic like that's so amazing
about it that's part of the immense
magic as i was thinking about that part
way through the episode is like they are
really good and it's and it is multiple
things colliding it's tom hiddleston's
performance it's in the writing it's in
the
other actors and whatnot it's in the
direction where yeah there are times
where you're like okay
it seems like he actually is kind of
getting on the same page and
and getting into the case but i feel
like it is that sort of thing of loki is
also impulsive and he is also
sort of plugged into wherever he is at
the current moment in terms of
opportunism
so yeah it does feel very natural to be
flip-flopping back and forth in terms of
yeah i
i know i love loki and i love watching
him but i have no idea if i should trust
him or not and that makes the stakes
really really work yeah you know even
though like you know they're like if
this doesn't go well i can't help you
out mobius you know and we're going to
have to
reset loki and even though we know
that's not going to happen it does make
the tension of
riding that razor's edge feel very alive
oh
absolutely they have fun with the
audience of
knowing that we have seen him arc into
someone who is good
but there's this little moment here
where
like this is where i'm so conflicted on
with loki myself like not conflicting
the sense of like do i like this guy or
not
conflicted on what side he's on truly
because when he's looking at the
ragnarok destruction file
it looks like heartbreak as you're first
reading it and you're you're
zooming in on his eyes and it feels like
there's this loss in this pain
and then it gets to the next scene where
he's with mobius explaining how he
solved the mystery of what this variant
is doing
and then he brings up yeah ragnarok i'm
sorry about your people he's like
yeah anyway like he could not give a
[ __ ] about
it i'm not concerned about it i don't
care about that i figured it out yeah
right yeah he's not at all concerned and
i couldn't tell if that's just in the
moment of
the excitement of solving it and uh then
being here like that's not the point
to be sad about this the point is i've
solved it
or if he is just it's just the fact that
he is the different loki the one from
avengers assemble
and not the loki who witnessed the
destruction of ragnarok and how
devastating and
how sad that all truly was for him you
know
uh so it's it's really good at making
you
i want to say you're like it shifts you
into different shoes
all the time sometimes you're in
mobius's perspective
sometimes you're right in loki's
perspective yeah
you know you're it's good at putting you
in both of their shoes
at any given moment depending on what
the perspective of the scene
is like to me this is just
damn fine filmmaking
writing as well yeah yeah it has a
really unique tone and that tone makes
it
like easy to shift between things that
are fun and quirky and then things that
are actually quite foreboding because i
loved how this episode had both
ends of the spectrum in terms of part of
the time you're you're just kind of
hanging out at the tva while mobius and
loki learn how to kind of feel each
other out and stuff like that but then
like later on
in the uh you know roxcart uh there's
some actual
tension and some like eeriness beyond
like that action and oh there's a
hurricane and stuff but like
you know watching a a set piece like
that play out that is both
physical in terms of oh what are all the
reset charges gonna do and you know how
are we gonna physically apprehend
this iteration of loki but there's also
this psychological
you know watching them face off is it
has multiple layers because you're like
okay is loki gonna
be able to find an inroad to this other
loki and learn some more about them is
loki gonna
you know stay on whatever weird moral
track we as the audience want him to
stay on
is he going to you know completely go
rogue is he going to team up with this
loki is he
out for himself solely and he doesn't
care about like it gets you thinking
about so many different
things while you're also doing the cool
comic book stuff
you know yeah that's what's what's
genius about this show
is you really don't know which direction
it's going to go
and it's it's mystery is so intriguing
in this execution they
there's such a great rhythm about it all
like the pulse to this was
so awesome you know like the
like i love the hangout stuff like as
you were talking about because that's
where i feel like you learned the most
about mobius
in the sense of he's he's kind of bored
he's he sees it all but he doesn't get
to experience it you know what i mean
it's like he's it's always an observant
perspective and a study and
that's why he seems like kind of
nonchalant about some
things or it's just about doing his job
and his purpose but then
like the conversation about the jet
skiing and like why don't you go do it
and you could just see this like
downtrodden side in him
who who has a yearning to just
experience a little bit and then
this experience by with loki is is
kind of instilling life into him
yeah and you know in a very different
way harkens back to that thing that loki
grapples with in the first episode of
sort of like well you know like
he's he recites that thing we're like
the time keepers made me and this is my
job and this is what i'm here for and
it's that acceptance of like i guess
there's just a cosmic purpose for me
and i can't really deviate from it
otherwise you know the
upper brass is going to come in so yeah
you can definitely see where mobius
you know being somebody so fan and
having this fascination with loki too
and like being a fan and things like
that like
even though some of that i'm sure is to
appeal to a manipulation
i feel like there's some authenticity
there too so yeah you can see
you know and even moby is like coming
into uh renslayer's office and being
like look i'm jazzed about this i want
to go out there you know like
this is going to be risky but you get
the sense that he's actually excited
based off that
yeah so i mean he he you get the sense
that there's
there's a yearning for more within him
there is this
i i do think there's a part of him that
has become like a bit hollow because
it's cool to see
like his own wilson silent in the first
portions with him and loki after
his conversation ravana he's like
impatient
and and angry and like annoyed easily
you know like that uh just when i saw
the task and he's getting annoyed with
loki
and i was i'm i like seeing those
different shades of owen wilson and it
just enhances the more realistic dynamic
of
these two being together you know
because sometimes you're just in
the the shoes of loki who is this
underdog or not even an
underdog but he's just he's nowhere near
the god level power
level you know like he's he's just
wearing a variant jacket
they label him variant he's in a suit
and tie he's working behind a desk
being told to study from the video files
watch videos
you know and he's really been demoted in
his own
life right and that's
where was i going with that i was
totally going somewhere with that and i
kind of totally lost my train of thought
remember for me john that's the only
super power i don't want
back for me john remember my remember my
train of thought here
okay loki
um if only we could reset the sacred
timeline of this review
well anyway yeah we're going with loki
being um
in this position sometimes you're in his
shoes where he is
he's so childlike in the sense of how
he's sort of being babies being parented
by
uh mobius in this dynamic but then
there's this boyish quality that comes
out from mobius through his experiences
with loki
and it's it's so fun like they are
the soul of this this show you know like
i i
i just love them both together and their
scenes together they're acting the way
they
react off each other the way they feed
the way they like um
uh feel each other out in these scenes
and i love how they still carried on
like taking a moment like we need to
take a break and they have these
philosophical debates about what is
free will and what is purpose and wh
why can't we ask why you know
things like that uh that were just so
intriguing
they managed to do everything like world
build move the plot
character build keep you emotionally
hooked be funny
be intense be exciting when we're in an
apocalyptic moment you can be
a horror film you know like you're doing
it all that's
it fires on all cylinders and i i can't
find
any sincere gripe i have with the show
yeah like so far i can't
and especially this episode this was
this was like top notch it was just so
exciting
it was like just getting in the field
and you're starting to figure it out and
then
loki like it's heartbreaking because
you're because the
what's heartbreaking about that moment
more so
than anything else when he goes through
to follow um
she doesn't want to be called loki but
yeah i mean we were saying it's
loki for so long ll but following lady
loki what's heartbreaking about that
is it's mobius who's calling after him
you know what i mean
it's not so much that loki's making this
choice to go there
it's more so how mobius might be like
i stuck my neck out for you man like i
don't know if i should trust you or not
clearly i'm starting to take a big
liking to you but maybe i shouldn't
should be on guard and yeah i took my
neck off for you and no loki damn it
and you're like no but i love your bond
yeah
yeah yeah and i wonder i mean like it
makes me obviously curious as to like
what that's gonna do
to their relationship because they're
gonna link up again at some point and i
wonder if they're gonna continually ride
this line of like well
okay that that wasn't good but then
again you you
some way led us to her you gave us the
next piece of the puzzle so you'll stay
you're resetting execution i don't know
like like i feel like we've seen
so many of the moments that have popped
up in all the trailers like marvel is
really good at doing so there's also
this sense of like okay act one is now
in place
yeah you know there's a ton like that's
the other magic is like
it seems like there's tons that could
lay beyond this point in the next four
episodes you know i mean we know that
lady loki and and
loki loki are gonna talk at some point
but like just the
scope of imagination in
play right now is so wide that yeah it
has this
really wonderful peripheral magic it
always feels like it's percolating and
alive in the back like it really is
transportive i guess
is like it really feels for this
you know 45 minutes to an hour that we
watched these first two episodes anyway
like
you are existing outside time you know
yeah yeah it really is magical
mm-hmm it's eclectic yeah it is like and
it's fascinating to me that the show the
episodes feel
so natural and they flow in such a
natural way because again
they don't have what i associate with
like a traditional
pace for these things and they manage to
jump back and forth between
yeah things that are more quirky and
quiet and character based toward things
that are more intense and more science
fictiony
well it doesn't feel like only a
continuation of the first episode
no you know what i mean like this feels
like a justified
episodic thing like it's cereal
but episodic and like every episode
feels like it's going to be doing its
own
wants to do its own unique thing to a
certain degree right you have a mix of
episodic and serial stories
yeah because sometimes you watch those
shows that they decide to go weekly and
you're like this could have just been a
binge
yeah and this you're like no every these
two episodes both feel eventful
yeah and and now you know being at the
end of this one
it is such a cliffhanger that makes you
just
like it enhances the anticipation
because now i'm like i gotta get episode
three
yeah and it still feels like a complete
s story told for the
episode yeah yeah yeah it's like loki
gets away
dang like yeah you could yeah yeah and
the whole time some moby is up against
everyone
everyone telling him not to trust him
and this is a terrible idea and everyone
just keeps talking down on him
and then loki does that and just makes
it look like loki's the traitor
yeah yeah really we don't even know
exactly why he did i like
it could be the the mysterious hints
that lady loki was leaving
right of of like i'm not doing this
because of
you you don't even know why i'm doing
this so he wants to go find out why
because maybe there's a power play here
maybe he is a little sincere
maybe he's just talking with everyone
and trying to see which side the line's
best for
his ultimate motive which is to stay
alive like he just
wants to live that seems like to be his
main motive is he's afraid of being
deleted so he has to play his cards
right
it's like maybe if that means taking
control of the tv in some way having the
power play
sure but i love how the show just
acknowledges all these things and like
they get the obvious [ __ ] out of the way
like oh like mobius calling him out on
okay so you want to just manipulate your
way get your hand on timekeeper take
over the tv like say it
right away lady loki being like it's not
about the tv
like just call he even says the plan of
like i could use your health take over
the tva says it right here in this
episode instead of waiting a while
you get you introduced lady loki in the
second episode so you know like yeah
they're getting the most obvious stuff
out of the way and
it's so you're entering the door of the
unknown much quicker
and and that's what makes this so
enthralling yeah and it's funny that it
is able to
spend its time the show like and take
its time but also
you know not waste its time because that
definitely caught me in this episode
like when mobius just rattles off like
the plan that everyone's been
speculating loki has but for the whole
show
you know and yeah like really taking the
the uh
the not taking the piss out of those
things a little bit you know in a way
that acknowledges
it's a clever you know it's like it's
meta and it's aware but it's also
clever because it at least alludes to
the idea that no we got
much bigger surprises and much more
intricate
uh you know machinations that we've
thought out and so
you know i mean obviously i wouldn't
expect i wouldn't expect the most
obvious outcome but when they do things
like that you know it enhances the fun i
think because it's like okay clearly the
writers are
steps ahead of me and in this day and
age where everyone's combing so
you know deeply and and finally
that's a special feeling i think it's
crazy how like
you said the scope is so large yet you
could feel there's this insidious
terror just sort of like encompassing
them like it's like this
virus claustrophobic yeah that's weird
there's like this
almost oppressive almost stark-like
nature
to it all that's not it's not a hundred
percent
there yet but you could feel essentially
the bleakness
rising and encompassing something from
the dart to shadow overcoming
yeah something is wrong i'm just not
entirely sure what beyond the obvious
things
i love it yeah i love it and then like
the fun scenes too and then
figuring out like uh the whole thing
with the very
like going to apocalypse going to pompeo
just how he just
relishes in this in the sadistic manner
of
like you're all going to die not a hint
of sympathy
and then you know you know that bothers
a character like mobius
yeah and i love that that it's it's
interesting because i mean obviously
loki's doing his thing and they're kind
of having a fun and games moment there
but they
even brought that back around because
the way the one minute man at the end is
like who cares these people are all
gonna die like why are you bothering to
be kind to them but you know it's one of
those save the cat moments that says
something about mobius at least as a
character
and it's interesting to see you know
iterations of that both
in that sense that he wants to branch
out and have a little more fun with his
place in the universe whatever uh but
also yeah he is
you know a a moral character well i
guess it's the tone of this
this scene too or is like in pompeii
that's very
they they have they don't believe him
they have
they think he's a lunatic he's a loony
they don't fear it at all and then
they'll be wiped out in a split second
yeah whereas uh the people there in the
alabama the rock song
rox cart um rox cart was the name of it
rox card but you know
roxanne knowns that store
but yeah rock's card yeah yeah it's
gotta be a riff on roxanne right
yeah it has to be yeah um
but uh yeah we're there they were like
sheltered up they're preparing for
to be wiped out yeah you know they're
literally negotiating evacuation or
trying and the guys being like
mistreating them in a scenario scenario
when
they're already living in fear and pain
yeah
so like that one's much more mean it
feels
plus tva agents are just assuming such
dicks but yeah but i love the
that they're they're alluding to a lot
and having you focus on a lot of things
that seem really interesting like would
ravana there's something there where i'm
like i don't fully trust your lady
what it is there's supposed to be a
romantic interest of king the conqueror
so maybe there's something like why are
you the only one who gets to talk to the
timekeepers yeah the way they build
up the presence of like the time keepers
are always watching
yeah and they're writing your history
they're looking at hard you
i'm wondering if the show's gonna do
something
one of those marvel mcu
things that might piss off people of
like there's no time keepers you know
i want oh god no that is something
they've
designed maybe yeah i mean i could
certainly
i could see a big lie being part of it
and you know maybe that'll
tie into kang somehow or maybe the big
lie will just leave the door wide open
for kang
yeah i'm not sure what it is but because
they do
so much emphasis every time like even
when you're in ravona's office there's
different
uh statues and busts of the time keepers
but at the same time
there's always a lingering shot or a
zoom or something especially on the
center one
yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah and then
they go down the elevator it zooms in on
them
like we don't why are we zooming in on
them exactly yeah it's like they are
it makes them a looming presence even
though we've only spoken of them
it feels like they're in the room and
most people in the in tva
don't know them and like not even not
even mobius does
yeah it's like how can mobius possibly
give like yeah you can talk to
timekeepers when he has never even met
that that was maybe
that was the only i think like actual
legit question that came up for me in
the episode was
why would that one minute man know the
exact location
of the time keepers to give to lady loki
if she's just one of many minute men
unless she's super special maybe because
moebius doesn't get to because he's an
analyst
could be yeah i mean that's fair maybe
the
timekeepers just really love their braun
his analyst job seems more important
and it seems like you know more
applicable to the time
keeping you know responsibility i would
imagine where you're
discerning events and proximities of
you know it's not as much i don't know i
yeah it doesn't seem like there's much
for a minute man and a time keyword to
talk about
yeah that wouldn't come through the
middle man
of an analyst you know
but then again maybe she's special well
guys um
i don't know what do you guys think on
the music too it's just
it's music it's so reflective and it's
so uh
it's distinct and they have like
multiple like so many great
different instruments that cue certain
motifs and stuff like i love
loki's motif that they keep playing this
like really disparate
i don't know what it is it almost sounds
like a voice but it could be a stringed
instrument or whatever like it's
it has like that norse culture around
the periphery and then
like ethereal sci-fi yeah yeah
it's beautiful i don't know it's my
favorite thing
it's kind of crazy that's crazy reset
the whole timeline
this [ __ ] just like woke me up
[Laughter]
ah still a little brain dead but i'm
awake now now you're you're you know the
truth now the universe
guys what'd you think about this episode
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click the notification bell hit that
like
button and hey let's do a p
daniel gallacher i want you to get i'm
branching out today i'm creating a
branch
timeline and you're gonna see that this
is gonna it's
it's gonna mess things up but i wanna
shout you on a totally different way
today daniel gallacher so
i just hope you're doing well and i
think you should apply for a new job
with the time variance authority think
of all the things we would have to talk
about i mean you could be all across
time and space you don't have to be from
scotland anymore you could find
daniel's gallacher from canada you could
find one from like malaysia maybe
there's a daniel gallacher living in
the arctic or something like that and
then you could round them all up and
then you could turn this into the one
where you wipe each one off the map
collect their power for yourself and
then ultimately ascend
as the one true nexus gallacher
so uh wouldn't that be fun no it would
be fun that would be fun good call john
yeah yeah yeah
and then we'll get another wilson
brother to hang out with you yeah i
don't know what he's super thank
you for being part of our patreon page